but your husband was on and I gotta be
honest with you Tom talk as much as I do
and that is a lot like when we were
interviewing I was like I have met my
match challenge acceptable but your
charity to those so you don't but do you
mind it or are you kind of like oh
that's a lot
look I Tom and I that was one of the
things that when we met we just got
along instantly because we first of all
I love a good storyteller so anybody who
can tell a good story I'm down with that
yeah and and I don't know what my family
was very vocal growing up so we were you
know exactly like talking and food that
was pretty much our whole existence yeah
and no I I love that he makes me laugh
all the time I mean I think that's he's
a great storyteller he's really a
storyteller I was like I was like lists
all the time and I was like oh god I'm
interviewing you
yeah I was like yeah I was like I forgot
I was just listening yeah we're gonna
have you guys over have dinner we can
tell lots more stuff oh my god it was
great I think the thing that's great
about both of you like meeting both of
you backstage is like you're super duper
famous but you're super duper like chill
and that doesn't always happen so like
congratulations on being normal like I
was asking you backstage like how do you
do everything that you do I'm completely
like Mary gray though I just listed a
thousand jobs you know what I love it I
love I love doing what I do I feel
really blessed to be able to do it and
and as I continue to do it I've been
working since I was 14 years old in this
business and I had a job here at this
studio when I was a teenager at this
music concert venue yeah called the
universal Amphitheatre now is the Harry
Potter right yeah I'm not into
stimulation
I was like oh my god the Dementors are
going to kill me so what I'll do that to
get away from it all do you do theme
parks well yeah we do do theme parks but
one of the things that we like to do and
probably people don't really think of us
as doing this as camping why would we
not think about that I don't know
because we live here and like I think
it's a great place to camp I know well
yeah there's tons of place in California
- yeah but we have a little Airstream
trailer and we just hook it up to the
back of the truck and we take it places
and it's kind of cool because sometimes
we'll come into a campground and it's
night so people don't really know like
people are usually asleep by then so
we're just like come in make a hell of a
lot of noise you know can you imagine
people the next day we go out there like
making their eggs
what like cooking over there like this
just got amazing
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going